it promises to be one of the most
dramatic elections in modern history
through the night we'll be taking you
through the twists and turns all the
while focusing on this the main aim of
every party in an election to get their
leader into 10 Downing Street and win a
majority of seats in parliament over
that winning line of 326 seats here's
the final result from last time around
and look you can see the Conservatives
won 318 seats but fell short of that
line by 8 seats and although labour
gained seats they finished with 262 so
we got a hung parliament the Tories had
to join forces with the DUP to form a
government this time they'll be hoping
to win back some of the 13 seats they
lost in 2017 so what do we watch out for
this time around well there could be
some big upsets and well-known faces
disappearing potentially from Parliament
including foreign secretary Dominic Robb
he's being targeted by the Lib Dems and
the so called remain alliance in his
constituency Asia and Walton in Duncan
Smith in Chingford and wood green he's
also at risk labour and he need a 2.6
percent swing to win it and even Labour
stalwart Dennis Skinner in bowls over
it's a traditional labour see it's but
he's been MP since 1970 but it voted
strongly to leave the EU the toy subsidy
well there but might the brexit party
split the votes and also you've got MPs
running against their former parties so
Frank field he's been a fierce critic of
labour for its anti-semitism and it
starts on brexit now he's running
against them in this old constituency
birkenhead traditionally very safe
labour seats we've got the leader of
changed UK Anna sue Bri she's running
against her former party the
Conservatives in Brock Stowe a leave
voting marginal but will she split the
blue votes and let labour in and former
Tory cabinet minister Dominic grieve
he's running against his old party in
beckons billed as an independent the
remain alliance have backed him and
won't be running candidates against him
but will that be enough this election
won't just be about the battle between
the two main parties it's also about
what's going on underneath the surface
for instance will brexit really decide
this election let's have a look at last
time around so this representation of
constituencies shows you how the UK
voted last time all of those seats back
in 2017 and this is the UK every
constituency there let's take those and
put them against how they voted in the
referendum we'll take all of those put
them on
short over here and you can see these
are the areas that mostly most strongly
to remain those areas voted most
strongly to leave as you go across this
chart here you can see a lot of blue
here and the Tories will be hoping to
turn more of these red dots blue win
those seats in other words and over here
in those remain areas labor and the
other parties will be hoping to get rid
of those blue dot and we have some
special guests to help analyze as the
results come in it might tell us that
the country remains quite sharply
divided about its future and in
particular about its relationship with
Europe and I think it might show us
something else and that is a breakdown
in the traditional basis of voting which
tended to be driven by socio economic
factors we could be entering a new era
of what I suppose I would call identity
politics all said it promises to be an
unpredictable dramatic night democracy
in action and Britain's political fate
potentially shifting again at Conway Sky
News